before we get into multiplying
let's just do a little bit of revision
it's always uh handy rather than
starting from a new idea
to connect things back to what you
already know okay
so so far we've been looking at a whole
bunch of different processes
actions things that can happen to
integers
or things that can happen to pairs of
integers and they interact with each
other
okay now those actions they have a
special name
they're called starts with an o does
anyone remember
actions that happen between numbers
operations fantastic
operations
okay now after you
do take two numbers two integers and you
put an operation between them
you'll get something at the other end
okay uh a result
if you like now for each operation
i suppose i should make that singular
sorry page operation
its result is a slightly different name
it is great to know those names
uh names are useful because they need to
describe things in detail rather than
saying you know
that thing the guy on the end ah
whatever you call him he doesn't have a
name okay
names for things are helpful so
let's think about the first operation
you've learned which was
oh it's a bit early in the morning okay
let's try this again i reckon you know
it
it's there i'll do it on the count of
three we'll all say it together right
the first operation on the count of
three one two three addition
yeah well done okay now i heard a couple
of different words for it right now are
we going to write down both of them
i think the more formal word is addition
but when you read out something which
uses addition we don't tend to say that
we tend to say plus which is what i
think i heard over this
part of the room okay so in brackets you
can say
plus that's what it is and when you add
two numbers together
one plus one equals two the thing you
get
on the end the result has a special name
what's it called
it starts with an s uh
it's a it's a sum it's a song uh we'll
get to solutions
shortly but this is what it's called
when you add numbers right
okay let's continue the pattern the next
operation is
minus or subtraction again again it's
got the same kind of pair names doesn't
it
as you can probably tell because it's
longer subtraction is the
more fall name but we tend to read
sentences as
three minus one we don't say three
subtract one that's a little awkward
now do you remember when you add things
together you get a sum
when you minus things when you subtract
things you don't get a sum do you what
you get
starts with a d it's a very common word
yeah
a difference well done because you can
actually
here in the words i said three minus one
equals two
because the difference between three and
one
is two okay all right now i asked you to
do five rows so there's one two three
four five okay now today we're going to
be doing
multiplication right so that's our third
row here
multiplication and just like addition
and subtraction
multiplication has a somewhat shorter
less formal name which is
times because we say you know five times
six
so you can put tons
now here's a new word for you what
happens
when you multiply two numbers together
what's the name of the thing on the
end it's called for people who might be
reading ahead
yes oh factors are very important they
are very connected to multiplication
i'll get to them in a second this one
that i'm looking for starts with the
p p and it's a product okay now it's
okay if you um
uh didn't know that i'm actually
expecting most of you not to know that
factors are the names of the two numbers
you multiplied so for instance i said
five times six how good are your time
tables
five times six is thirty that's right so
what i've got here let's get some new
colors shall we
at 30 on the end that's the product
and fact is a great word um i hope most
of you have heard of that before
what are they the factors are five and
six okay
so you've got two of them you can
sometimes have more if you like but here
i just got
two factors now i've got an empty
group here we're going to get to him in
a little more detail but since
we have the table i think we can finish
it off what will be the last operation
we put on there yep
division um
yes uh there's a low battery that's fine
that's okay
he complains all the time now
division uh that's the name what what is
it does it have a short
name like the others division
what are we usually called yeah yeah
it's kind of divide but that's kind of
the same word isn't it like it's just
the
you know edition add subtraction
subtract
multiplication multiply so divide is
actually there
i i don't think i really have it has a
special name apart from that so i'm
actually just going to
leave that now here's another fancy word
for you
we're going to dwell more on this in a
future lesson but when you divide two
things together six divided by
two it's called uh yes dividend
now okay the word we've got no actually
i'm gonna i'm gonna pause on that we'll
come back to that word
oh will it be me it probably will be me
next time on friday
uh we'll come back to the dividend and
the divisor what i'm after
the result along the end is called
it's a weird word it's hard to spell too
quotient
but i'm only putting him there so that
the table is nice and complete
we'll revisit him another time okay or
her
i don't know if the question is